don't miss this amazing opportunity from
Nature's blends to get your finest
premium black seed oil and shilajit to
get that energy levels back up check
them out now
this man proposed to his wife in KFC and
a journalist mocked them and guess what
Allah had a plan and he is the best of
plants look at what happens here is the
video of him proposing to her at KFC and
then being mocked by this arrogant
stubborn snob
[Applause]
this is what the journalists had to say
this snob big-headed arrogant woman love
African men are so broke they even
propose at KFC they have absolutely no
class I mean who proposes at KFC because
you live in a materialistic world and
everything is about Aesthetics and what
you show I mean looking at the picture
yeah you're probably fake as hell
probably your hair is fake your
eyelashes are fake yeah your lips are
probably fake everything about you is so
fake that you think everyone has to be
fake like you whoever the hell you are
and guess what happened guys subhanallah
and let me tell you something the
prophet salallahu said the best
Buttercup is in the wedding that is done
small and there is even studies that
show this that people who are married in
a simple wedding are much much more
happier
but we will take that article over what
Messengers told us 1400 years ago this
is the state of the ummah but anyways
guess what happened people saw the
journalists comments and guess what
check this out so kulula I don't know if
it's a brand hey mazani's favorite
couple your honeymoon
company holidays are giving you a
holiday in Cape Town including flights
and five night accommodation it doesn't
stop there check this out guys yes guys
in the sweetest guys is the sweetest
story ever please DM me my jewelry
company will donate with these two
beautiful Rings worth 450 I don't know
what they are they deserve they deserve
rose gold with diamonds
raincoats that will take away all your
data data worries unlimited data for one
year for only one year well it's all
bloody cheap anyways KFC proposal to
keep the wedding excitement open view is
giving the couple of 42 inch TV and
fully installed decoder so many people
from different companies came together
to make this couple's wedding dream come
true and Allah works in mysterious ways
guys you might want to mock somebody and
arrogance this issue of arrogance which
it believes was involved in which caused
his demise
never be arrogant never look down on
people because Allah will humiliate you
this goes to those religious righteous
folks these righteous piety attack
individuals who look down on individuals
Allah for you in your place oh I never
tolerates arrogance from the Muslim or a
non-muslim yes so much so that even
Tamir said somebody who holds upholds
justice justice Allah will give them
Victory even if they're a confirmation
so we ask Allah that if they are I don't
know if they're Muslim or not if they're
Muslim may Allah
and you know hopefully you know they
have a blessed marriage inshallah in a
nutshell that's all I wanted to say KFC
whatever it is guys I know many people I
know an individual who actually told me
that he landed with a bloody helicopter
and guess what his marriage ended what a
couple of weeks a couple of months
stop living for others do it for
yourself and your wife stop trying to
please others most people are doing
these weddings and these big lavish
things not even for themselves they're
doing it so somebody can come and say
did you see zainab's wedding ban you
saying up and your wedding yeah it's not
that you have you seen if you are yeah
okay oh did you see Ahmed landing on the
helicopter probably
yeah forget living for others live for
Allah that is where you will find your
true Freedom till next time
[Music]